en el círculo dibujado la medida del
ángulo central g
h la medida del ángulo central
es de 3 medios radiales cual es la
longitud del arco g h tenemos este
problema y lo primero que quiero hacer
es bautizar el ángulo
h como el ángulo theta va a ser este
ángulo aquí que por cierto es un ángulo
central pues está anclado en el centro y
sabemos que teta tiene una medida del
ángulo g
h que por cierto son tres medios
radiales ahora bien preguntémonos qué es
lo que queremos queremos la longitud del
arco g h es decir está que voy a llamar
s quiero saber cuánto vale s que es la
longitud del arco g h y además sabemos
está que escrito en el círculo dibujado
que el radio vale 6 centímetros es decir
de un punto al centro que es el radio
vale 6 centímetros ahora la pregunta es
como encuentro el valor de s
y para ello resolver cuánto vale el
valor de ese sería muy bueno preguntarme
qué relación hay entre el radio el
ángulo y s es decir la longitud del arco
habrá alguna relación entre ese ere y
theta y bueno lo que yo me doy cuenta es
que ese sub tiende el ángulo theta el
arco s sub tiende el ángulo central de
está y además theta está dada en
radiales por lo tanto si hay una forma
de escribir la relación que existe entre
theta r&s y la relación que hay es la
siguiente como s sub tiende el ángulo
theta entonces theta es igual a s entre
el radio y más aún cuando theta está
dada en radiales porque justo esa era la
definición de radiante se acuerdan un
radial era la medida del ángulo queda
suspendido por un arco cuya longitud era
un radio usando esa misma lógica
entonces tenemos que te dan es igual al
arco entre el radio justo esta era la
definición de la medida angular
en radiales y bueno ya que tenemos esto
aquí podemos empezar a pensar qué es lo
que tenemos y qué es lo que no tenemos
lo primero que se me ocurre hacer es
pasar el radio del otro lado para que no
está dividiendo entonces voy a
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por r y aquí me queda r que divide jerry
que multiplica se van y entonces me
queda que s es decir la longitud del
arco que se tiende a teta es igual al
radio por theta otra forma de ver esta
relación y bueno otra forma que nos va a
servir bastante porque entonces que
tenemos ya sabemos cuánto vale el radio
y también ya sabemos cuánto vale el
ángulo t está dado en radiales por lo
tanto ese que es nuestra incógnita ya
podemos obtener la s va a tener que ser
igual a quien el radio vale 6
centímetros por lo tanto vamos a ponerlo
aquí en radio vale seis centímetros teta
vale tres medios radiales entonces por
tres medios y esto cuánto va a ser igual
seis centímetros por tres medios es lo
mismo que seis por tres 18 entre 2 que
es 9 o 6 entre 2 que es 3 por 3 es 99
centímetros por lo tanto la longitud del
largo que yo esté
buscando es de 9 centímetros es decir la
longitud del arco que era sub tendido
por teta y ya hemos acabado con esto
logramos resolver este problema